I've owned kavik River Camp now for a
little over a year last year one of the
things I did my food trailer my dry food
storage used to be out here on the pad I
thought I would move my food trailer all
the way back there to keep it away from
clients error in judgment on my part I
don't like having to go almost a mile to
get the dry storage because the
Predators can hide behind anything and
that's what they did this spring they
just hid and tried to ransack me as I
went through and that's that is way
beyond my comfort zone I'd you know I
always say don't don't be a pork chop
but I made myself right into one in
order to protect her food storage on
camp sue will enlist a piece of
machinery from the Second World War the
nod well
this thing is pretty freakin cool it has
tank controls tank tires that's what it
used to be now it's a vehicle 73 years
old but it still runs you know it may
have 10 to 12 flat tires out of 12 but
it still rolls the biggest issue getting
it from where it is to where I want it
to live do we need to do some groundwork
first or am I just going to tear it up
bringing it over not just parking or not
okay and I'll guide you when you're
coming to come around through the bushes
over here I'll get the water line out of
the way because we had a water ride done
with tearing up water lines and then
I'll stand and I'll guide you right up
into this spot here make sure you pull
straight in and we'll get the creditor
level as possible it's he's nipping
entry level
I want to go inside things are gonna
fall over there's no way to help it who
cares if paper towels hit the floor I do
care if something glass does just open
it up and see this is not going to cut
it let's get you down there anything
that may cause a problem
those'll jiggle they won't be bad
there is always potential for things to
break and get damaged things will bounce
off I'll have a lot of cleaning to do
once I move it but it all looks
basically good on this ends time to just
shut the door lift the stairs lock them
down all right
I'm gonna kick the tires like the fires
and get that thing rolling
and see if that's 73 year old piece of
equipment can make it work